oh the president tweets out about Robert
Muller tweets tweets out about Jeff
Sessions about the witch-hunt
he was very clear and saying that no
it's fake news most media's not the
enemy of the people but the fake news
ones are because they don't tell the
American people the truth what does the
president do how do you how should he be
dealing with this cloud that has been
hovering over his head with no evidence
whatsoever like for example Paul
Manafort there's nothing about Russia
nothing about the president nothing
about the campaign nothing about
collusion it was a 2005 tax case but
Hillary Clinton's never been indicted
how does he how does he navigate what he
believes and what I also agree with his
unfair and a witch-hunt leading into
this midterm okay I think he can do
three things they'll be very decisive
and that would change the whole picture
the first is let me just point out to
everybody in the audience 98 or 99 % of
what Moana is doing is not covered by
sessions recusal over the Russian
campaign incident 98 or 99 cent sessions
if he did his job could intervene
tonight or tomorrow and would be totally
within his authority and he should
number 2 the president ought to take
every single example we're talking about
and simply declassify it I mean I want
to see every decision memo about
Benghazi where the Obama team
consciously decided to lie the American
people I want to see all the decision
memos about Hillary Clinton the
president can order them released I mean
he has the ability by executive order
say I want them out by next Thursday
don't give me this baloney about it's
going to take 22 years get him out third
I think we ought to look very carefully
at what this case is all about molars
heard a bunch of very left-wing
Democrats they are clearly a hunting
party and I think the president should
challenge Motorhead on Moeller he should
say the president I should say to Muller
I dare you to hold a press conference
and tell the American people any
evidence you have that you think is
relevant to why you are losing heart
give us any
once you have because I don't think
Muller has any evidence and I think
it'll be embarrassing how little does
matter 4k soon as he's gone over he's
gone over there
I think that's embarrassing a 2005 tax
case the judge even said it put the
screws to him so he sings or composes to
either prosecute or impeach Trump let's
not kid ourselves and the judge said
that to Muller's team all right mr.
speaker good to see you as always thanks
for being with us